when you
get enough interception meaning
awareness of your internal mechanisms
and all your emotions right and you
start to make contact with your most
traumatized parts and like start to like
love them and surface then make them
more explicit share them through
relationship they start to feel better
over time that is your direct connection
to spirit like that part is also your
direct connection to your intuition into
spirit and so what can feel like
intuition can sometimes be a dissociated
trauma response and like a subtle
underneath that is what the intuition is
the part that's most traumatized is
usually the part that's most sensitive
to intuition too um and so when you can
help that part become more explicit and
more regulated um and then you start to
listen to it because that's the whole
point of an illness right as we were
talking earlier about is like to listen
to your body when you can actually
listen to the part that was
suicidal or
super angry or depressed and you can
start to improve your relationship with
those parts and go what are you what are
you what are you trying to tell me right
now
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
today on the show is maston kipp mastin
is a number one best-selling author he's
a speaker and creator of what's called
functional life coaching
basically maston takes your
problems whether they be internal or
manifesting external and looks at
trauma he is an expert in the area of
trauma and trauma doesn't always have to
be something that you wear on the
surface it can be on the inside and so
he has such a deep understanding for
um for
how the mind works and how the body
works and where this trauma is stored uh
he his his scope is just really great
and um it's also very very practical and
very functional so the the interview
took um
it started off in a place that i didn't
think we'd be because he is such an
expert in trauma and we
i guess maybe it's not that far-fetched
but
we talked about relationships and so i
guess the most amount of trauma feels
like it happens in a relationship so
perhaps it's the ideal place but we also
talk about emotional intelligence
emotional regulation
uh we talk about uh intuition
and uh rewiring the nervous system um so
we get into sort of the nuts and bolts
of of what happens inside the body as a
result of trauma
and and then some true action points for
what you can do next um where you can go
to get help what you can read and
eventually just how you can live a more
balanced
life from an emotional standpoint and a
physical standpoint so enjoy the episode
thanks for having me on danica this is
like so cool oh my god i'm so i'm so
glad it finally happened i know we're
not in person but um it's like just
making the connection yeah you know
still in person to come but um 100 and
what what's happening what's happening
behind you right there like what oh what
is that
it's uh
so i had a friend commissioned some art
for me i gave her the creative direction
to
use like desert i'm in arizona so like
desert landscape kind of colors like
nudes and browns and i wanted red in
there because red is a my favorite color
and
um kind of go with this sort of phoenix
rising sort of vibe and that
thing so
i said i need something behind me for my
interviews
so yeah it's awesome i love it that's it
thank you it's gorgeous well
aesthetically
i should bring up the fact that you're
not wearing your classic black t-shirt
you're wearing a white
button down and a black tie so
what's that all about well it's actually
back to roots so i it's very long story
i guess i'll get into it briefly so
i used to dress like this and then i
kind of disowned it for a while and very
long story short um i don't i haven't
really talked about this publicly so
this may be the first time um on my
mother's side uh i'm a dupont and so my
fifth grandfather back
was e.i dupont who founded a dupont
company
and you know i do trauma work right and
we try to help people not uh not have
adverse experiences and the dark side of
the dupont family
is that you know they made a lot of
gunpowder and they contributed to
killing a lot of people
and you know they supplied the union
with gunpowder so it was you know
they're on the right side of history but
there's a lot of death in my lineage and
i found out recently i was talking to a
cousin of mine
and she informed me that we actually and
i looked this up and verified it the
dupont company actually made the
plutonium that was a part of nagasaki
and hiroshima
that was a part of the manhattan project
and my whole life i felt this like
need to stop something that my family
created and so last year i couldn't walk
for like six months and it all kind of
boiled down to my body didn't want one
more dupont
causing trauma in the world uh very
unconscious very you know uh
subtle uh stuff but when i got in touch
with it so many things i was doing made
complete sense
um and so a part of you know disowning
that identity was you know i grew up
wearing suits and ties all type of stuff
i'm kind of coming back into it but on
my own terms now
so it's kind of a reclamation process so
thanks for noticing that by the way um
yeah from a new perspective yeah and
it's interesting because you know i
represent a lot because i do trauma work
i work with a lot of people from many
different backgrounds and i'm a white
male i have a privileged background
privilege history plural lineage i
represent the oppressor in so many cases
right
so i'm trying to do my part to end the
cycle on my side because my family was
the oppressor and causing so many
problems for so long
and in fact i have a little book here at
regular hq it's like a little old-school
dupont like notebook um with kuan yin
over it kind of like it's kind of sort
of metaphorically is like let's like
cleanse this lineage let's like not
do this anymore you know so it also made
sense why why do i do trauma work and
finding that out made a lot of sense for
me wow that's like a full circle like we
just started and ended the circle of
like
right there totally yeah i mean like i
mean i'm definitely going to keep you
for a lot longer but sure yeah of course
but that is fascinating i mean like so
many words come to mind you telling that
story like of course the one that i you
know have heard from you that i say all
the time to people like the issues are
in the tissues or you know cellular
memory and you know obviously the
trauma itself so um
how
maybe even just like
what happened for
context for sure example you know you
said you couldn't walk for six six
months
very intense that's a very intense would
that be described as a somatic response
oh you could call it that yeah and i it
was funny not it was not funny but it's
funny now um
my so i have i know what supination
means so you take your feet and they're
kind of like supinated they kind of
curve in like this and on themselves so
i've had more and more supinated feet
over the years because i do seminars and
i'll do seminars for
four to
14 days sometimes depending on which
seminar we're doing and i'll walk for 10
to 12 hours a day and so the more i
would walk the more supine they would
get i didn't have a routine for that
and they've been getting progressively
worse since i was about 25 and i'm 39
now um and so last year with coven and
stuff like that i think the emotional
impact of everything plus you know
decades plus of all this walking my feet
were so supinated
i just couldn't stand i couldn't walk
like the fascia just on the bottom of
the feet and the ankle and it's actually
interesting it all originated my left
ankle
on the inside the medial side of my left
ankle is where the whole tension pattern
starts it goes up my body and kind of
crosses over and the right side is
intense too but the left side is like
super intense
but what would happen is that the left
side would spasm and freak out and then
nothing would happen on the right side
and then that would release and then the
right side would go and they would
alternate and i talked to osteopaths i
talked to
orthopedic surgeons i went down down the
list of people
what is this diagnosis and nobody nobody
had a diagnosis for me which drove me
nuts because i'd like to understand what
i'm working with so i define my own
diagnosis which is sort of an error to
einstein einstein calls uh quantum
entanglement spooky action at a distance
when two you know particles do the same
thing but they're not in contact so i
just called it spooky fascia at a
distance because i know what else to
call it i don't know what to call it but
they would alternate back and forth and
some people were suggesting surgery and
stuff and i got with an incredible
osteopathic doctor who understands the
omt which is osteopathic manipulation
which is a subset of osteopathy that
only a few doctors really understand so
they do all the md training all the do
training
and then they take this like extra you
know two or two year you know deep dive
into human anatomy and the fascial
system so they understand like how to
like manipulate fascia in a way to help
it release in a way that nobody else
really understands so i combined that
with you know that work and then
uh cupping myofascial release john
barnes style myofascial release and then
my own you know therapy that i was doing
and in august uh so i wasn't walking was
not going well i was taking tons of
nsaids toward all wasn't working which
is crazy to think about
it's crazy to think about and then in
august of 2020
i was just like what do you want me to
know
right just like there you go what do you
what what what do you want right um
because i understand i'm a trauma guy i
do all that i do this works with my
clients all the time and the [ __ ] i mean
the fascia has so much memory of trauma
which we could talk about that's so
important but
um in august of 2020 i had this
myofascial session and that evening
like
i wasn't on drugs but i had a full-on
psychedelic experience of like literally
a thousand memories of all this
abandonment kind of coming back to me
all coming from the same kind of pattern
and i held my foot and i was crying and
i was holding myself and processing
because i understand how to regulate
stuff
and then at the end of this process i
could see how all this pain in my life
came from this one pattern
one pattern and i looked at my foot and
i held my foot and i believe you talk to
your body it has parts we know that and
i said i wouldn't want to move forward
if i were you either i was holding my
left foot
and it was all about maternal
abandonment basically
which is not my mom's fault she had a
broken back and stuff like that but it
was like really powerful and so i said
look um if you can release and let go
i'll pay attention to you from now on
like all i'll like i'll be there for you
and we'll make sure that my team knows
everybody knows
and after that like got better very
quickly um and then my performance coach
uh dear friend adam cobb uh came into
asheville and we've been training since
october every day and this guy he trains
nba guys he trains actors entrepreneurs
and i'm there he's a national i'm like
can we take a step let's just take one
step because i can't really walk right
now and we worked it up from like
literally one step
uh back in october to like this
afternoon session we were like doing all
kinds of crazy pliability and jumping
around and stuff like that and i've
dropped like 50 pounds since then too so
it's been like a whole
releasing but then i talked to my cousin
lexi
uh
i don't know that must have been like
november december of last year and she's
like hey dude by the way the dupont and
that those two pieces like went together
because it was not just a maternal
abandonment there was a part of me that
felt that cellular memory that like my
family did bad stuff
right and was contributing to a lot of
things so it was very it was very uh it
was a very intense 2020 to say at least
it's super intense
yeah when the trauma guys trauma comes
up
[Laughter]
that's but i think you know i always
people want to hold
their teacher or guru
or whoever it is that they look to for
advice to be perfect they're like
if you do this you should and i and i
stop and i'm like yeah really how the
hell do you and why do you think they
got into this in the first place because
they need it yeah exactly right like you
don't get passionate about something if
it's just natural and easy like you are
passionate about the things that you
want and that you seek and that you need
and so i almost think it's a rite of
passage that someone that's speaking
about something is going through it and
having heart because it's like you're
gonna figure it out because it's your
you know it's that's your that's what
you're here to do and and and it's
calling you so i think that it's totally
admirable to speak to that story and to
and to describe it and
really
validate sort of
this space yeah well i appreciate that
and i do my best like i don't literally
do this but like i'll pick my nose in
front of my clients if they put me on a
pedestal because it's not about that um
and people like i mean it's cool to
aspire and be inspired by somebody but i
think that perfectionism is like
doesn't belong in the trauma-informed
space
right because like you can't expect your
teacher or your mentor to be perfect
because everybody's nervous systems gets
dysregulated and
um
that's not really a trauma-informed
approach right so what i don't do with
my clients in fact this is the first
time i've talked about it
publicly what i don't do with my clients
is i don't talk about what i'm going
through in the moment with them because
that wouldn't help them feel safe but i
will definitely talk about something
like this now because i've gone through
it i've processed through it i've you
know regulated through it i feel really
good about it my body's super pliable i
ended up becoming a tom brady fan which
i wasn't happy about uh during the
process because his playability stuff is
so good
um
but i was not a tom brady fan before but
unfortunately i am now um and that's all
adam's fault but yeah
that tom brady's great to cheer for you
know he's amazing what i loved about tom
brady that i didn't get is that adam
helped me understand because he's a long
time tom brady fan is that like he's the
underdog like even now seven super bowls
in next season they're like well they're
not favored to win next year because i
mean in my opinion because he's old
right like he's kind of like an underdog
because he's sort of he's not at the
pinnacle of his sort of like the culture
like the quintessential age for a
quarterback so he's an underdog because
you're like can the 40 some year old do
it this year totally yeah and i i i i
gained massive respect because i read
his book tb12 method and he actually
talks about in his book which i was like
whoa okay tom okay okay tom okay um he
talks about his pliability process
obviously hydration and stuff like that
but he talks about the way in which he
creates pliability in the body which is
emotional uh fascial flexibility right
is in the positions that would cause the
active motion positions that would cause
his body negative trauma is what he
calls it or impact trauma they do those
same positions but they apply what's
called positive trauma or i think you
know trigger point type work or rolling
out type work in those positions that
are active so it's not like a static
stretch it's like he's moving his body
in the position of like throwing while
releasing the muscles and stuff like
that and i was like that makes a lot of
sense because that's what we do with
people emotionally we help them go back
into emotionally difficult situations
and memories and positions and then have
a different experience i was like oh man
am i a lot like are we we're so on the
same page like no fi okay you know like
it was like a it was a it was a it was a
come to jesus mode adam adam would be
happy with that though he's definitely a
tom brady fan
that's cool that's really cool okay i
want you to so i feel like one of the
things that people and look like here i
am going
mom or dad like you know my childhood
trauma and they're like
they're like i didn't beat you i didn't
you know what you know i didn't you know
whatever like there's so many things
that come up when you tell somebody like
i have trauma and i think that it's the
education
of the word trauma that needs to be
uh absolutely emphasized and promoted
everywhere because
it's it's not what
most people think it is so that's
accurate like explain trauma
um to everyone when you really
understand what trauma is and then you
do your trauma work like your life
improves significantly like it really
does because like you start to feel
better your mental health improves your
relationships improve finances improve
and that's just not hyperbole like
there's like so much data like
peer-reviewed metadata now across many
different spectrums and populations to
suggest that trauma work is so valuable
it hasn't made its way into the
mainstream american psychiatric
association's dsm diagnosis yet
unfortunately
but
when you look at what trauma is right
i've i'm a nmd which is not a medical
doctor okay that's what i am okay so i
don't have any credentials i don't have
any certifications but i have like 20
000 hours working with people uh over a
decade plus and we've gotten incredible
outcomes with people um and we're
starting to pre-clinical trials in our
work to document the efficacy so we can
start to publish papers on it
um but
when you look at what trauma is there's
so many definitions depending on who you
talk to right you talk to like a
standard psychiatrist or psychologist
they'll give you one definition you talk
to a neuroscientist will give you a
different definition um you talk to you
know someone like bethel vanderkolt
he'll give you a certain definition or
you know dr bruce perry amazing he'll
give you a definition dr steven portrays
all these people give you different
definitions and they're all in the right
direction so what i've basically done is
try to summarize in a way that people
can understand
and
it's a little verbose but i'll do my
best to say it slowly okay
so trauma and emotional trauma is any
experience of threat
disconnection
isolation or immobilization that's
important understand it's threat
disconnection isolation or mobilization
that
disregulates
the optimal functioning
of your body of your health of your
immune system of your nervous system of
your spirit of your brain of your
emotional body right
and it has to have a long-term effect
it's not something that happens like
momentarily when you move on so if you
have a dysregulated nervous system
immune system endocrine system uh
emotional system brain
uh
body
uh emotions mind spirit any of those
things not operating functionally and
optimally then you are most likely in
some type of emotional trauma response
because our goal is to be
optimal functioning and to be able to
experience adverse experiences but then
like creatures in nature like shake it
off and then proceed in the present
moment right but when we get stuck and
when we're in anxiety or depression uh
perfectionism you know go down the list
of all the emotions right and then all
the different diagnoses are out there
ptsd the id ocd all the d's right those
are all trauma responses and so it's so
much more than a physical injury people
think that it has to be a dramatic
physical injury that that's traumatic
that's blunt force trauma or a capital t
trauma but trauma can be
you know your parents weren't
emotionally in tune with you right
there's a difference between physical
survival needs and emotional needs right
so you have your physical needs met and
still be traumatized because your
emotional needs weren't met right um and
it's an emotional game so like with
physical trauma um you know you see
bruises you can see things right um but
with emotional trauma like they're it's
it's invisible now you can you can get
data from the nervous system and from
the body now we can kind of start to
measure these things but it's still a
newer science it's a softer science but
it's more or less invisible but it shows
up in
behaviors that help us not move forward
to achieve goals not operate
functionally defiance rebellion
all those different things so if you're
in any of those responses the likelihood
that there's emotional trauma there are
significantly high and and also there's
a a big correlation now between
emotional trauma and chronic disease
right so if you look at most chronic no
one catches diabetes or no one catches
fibromyalgia you catch covid right but
that's an infectious disease but you
don't catch fibromyalgia
and or you know uh endometriosis or
whatever right there's so many different
chronic illnesses and what's really
interesting is the world's leading
functional medicine doctors
um are starting to see sometimes
correlation and sometimes causation
between emotional trauma and chronic
illness and that sounds like like almost
like victim blaming like my thoughts
craig gave me cancer or something like
that but that's not exactly the take the
take is when you have emotional or
nervous system or immune or endocrine
dysregulation it makes your body more
susceptible to pathogens
right and so the pathogen will enter the
body and then sort of metastasize or
nest or start to materialize in the
areas of most susceptibility which is
why when you look at for example certain
cancers everybody has cancer for the
most part the reason why someone gets
cancer that's like
you know life-threatening is because the
immune system doesn't recognize as a
threat anymore and you have to look at
why is that yes environmental toxins are
the main cause of cancer genetic cancers
are very small percentage of cancers but
when you look at like what body did this
cancer enter
right and what was going on in its
nervous system and immune system and
endocrine system
and you realize that well the state of
that person's body and immune system
endocrine system was dysregulated
because of an emotionally traumatic
experience then they're more at risk to
be able to get chronic illness right
so it's not a blame the victim situation
but you know just like with kovid covet
is a metabolic disease right if you are
metabolically healthy the likelihood
you're going to get it or be hurt by is
very low right and so the same thing is
true for a lot of chronic illnesses is
that like we get chronic illness and the
reason why
it shows up in certain areas is because
that's the earth needs our attention
right so there's a lot of it's not that
it's like okay just do your trauma work
like you got to do your functional
medicine work you got to do allopathic
stuff you ha those things are important
but it's the emotional components that
we're missing but we're starting to see
it now and so there's a direct
correlation between those things so that
was a very long answer to your question
but i tried to give them as much context
as i could i want to take a second to go
a little bit further into what you were
just saying about because let's face it
cancer affects so many of us and um
directly or indirectly
um well i guess it could be i'll call
directly if it's
someone you care about so uh
what when you say it's giving you a sign
and i and i truly i look at disease and
i look at i look at um
disease in the body disease or or um
issues as being
i'm thankful for the sign right instead
of just dropping dead it's like thanks
for the warning right so i try to
reframe it to be like a it's a good
alert system and now it's not pleasant
but dying is much worse
give an example of a cancer situation
and be like okay now you can see it came
into this space into this part of their
body this is what it's trying to tell
your body's trying to tell you do you
have a scenario sure and just remember
i'm an nmd so which is not a medical
doctor right here's what i can tell you
and i'm a double and
not a nun yet so um
so so here here's what's important
understand okay so the major so we're
talking cancer so i have a personal
history with that not in not for me
personally but people that i love have
been through very intense things and
we've seen some amazing things happen
with them so when you're addressing
something like cancer or any chronic
illness there's multiple levels that's
wise to proceed on right so you want to
proceed on the allopathic level which is
like go see you know an oncologist and
get an opinion it's just a freaking
opinion but do not ask for a prognosis
because they are not god right so if
someone says to you oh yeah this made
much months to live like the answer you
should put in your head is yeah if i go
with you that's right if i go with you
then i have six months to live right but
that is not true for everybody right so
you want a diagnosis not a prognosis
first and foremost right because the
fear just makes it worse um so you but
you want allopathic right
you also then want you know functional
medicine which is looking like what's
the root cause what's happening in your
body right like in terms of your
biomarkers inflammation levels and you
know all the different you know um
genetic testing that's available you
know you can take cancer and get it
genetically tested and see if there's
different sequences and specific
treatments for that specific cancer now
or clinical trials um omnisec and
different things like that there's so
many different places you can go
so you wanna do your functional approach
and then you wanna do like more of a
naturopathic approach too where you're
looking at like you know naturopathic
oncology which is a different opinion
right you might be getting i don't know
like uh
like mistletoe imported from canada
because it helps with your immune system
or things like that um and then you want
to look at the emotional level
right and at the emotional level it's
like can you actually build a
relationship with cancer
right because it's in you as you now
there's a part of you right so like can
you build this like with any part can
you build a part part of it with you um
and you also want to look at your
environment right so your environment is
like are there mold toxins are there
issues in the environment that are like
carcinogens and stuff like that and you
want a really full spectrum approach
right and you want people on your team
whether it's cancer someone else who
believe in full remission
right because hope is not the doctors
who say like you know i don't want to
give you false hope they don't
understand hope hope is binary you
either have hope or you don't have hope
right it's not like there's nothing is
false hope false hope is [ __ ] i can
say that right i can say [ __ ] yeah
you can say all the [ __ ] you want yeah
okay cool and just like with just like
with uh prescription medication there's
no such thing as side effects with
prescription medication there's effects
and there's effects that the
pharmaceutical company wants to
highlight and there's a downplay but
they're all the same effect right that's
why glaucoma medicine became latisse
yeah
totally yeah it's all marketing right um
i correct doctors all the time with this
word side effect um so you wanna have a
hopeful team
and you want to your best like regulate
the people in your life and get support
so that like you know it doesn't become
this fear cluster of people around you
and stuff like that
um but it's about developing the
relationship so you know i can think of
people
who you know
it's hard to say like where is the
cancer and what is it specifically
related to you know i would defer to
maybe like a louise hay book on that um
and also there's an incredible book
called the healing power of illness
um that's kind of old school book
written by psychologists but the
assumption of that book just like you
just said danica is that it can
you you perceive symptoms of an illness
as a message from your body that
something needs attention right um it's
a brilliant book but what i can tell you
most of the time when i look at people
who have had different types of cancers
right
is that um
there's a big
self-sacrifice in the cancer personality
types where they tend they not always
those we don't it's not all or never but
on a spectrum right bell curve spectrum
a lot of people with cancer
put themselves last or they've become
invisible or they've deferred they don't
have a sense of internal sense of agency
and the cancer comes in as an
opportunity
opportunity for them to like take charge
of their healing right i think probably
the best example of that is a woman
named chris carr who write crazy sexy
cancer um and she basically talks about
how she became the ceo of her health and
she talks about how you know all the
doctors said you know she had lung
cancer and all this stuff my daughter
said she had this much time to live and
she's like outpaced all of them by like
decades plus right she's chris carr is
an incredible human being
um
and you know she did all the work that i
just suggested and she still has it in
her body but she's living with it she's
living in an out mostly alkaline state
and she's doing her emotional work but
each l each uh chronic illness has a
different purpose right if you think
about diabetes not type one but type two
diabetes and pre-diabetes i would ask
you like what's not sweet about your
life
right what's like what's missing because
you know sugar is an analgesic that
numbs pain um people focus on sugar and
dopamine but it's really the analgesia
and the pain numbing that's really
important or like if you have
endometriosis or something like that
it's like
what's not being born through you right
like things like that because you want
to look at that level it's not the only
level that you want to look at but you
want to look through those levels
to understand like there's a there's
there's more going on here than like an
iso and itis or an odeosis or whatever
right there's there's more happening
here than just the diagnosis itself does
that make sense
absolutely absolutely definitely very
lewis hay like you know looking at like
where it's coming if you you know you
can't speak it's like what are you not
saying and if you have a sore throat
it's like sorry if you have a sore
throat it's like what are you not saying
things like that it's like looking at
the body as um
a road map like to kind of like leading
you to the space she had a huge data set
by the way she worked with tens of
thousands of people i mean there's a
reason why you can hear your life sold
like 40 50 million copies right like
yeah i mean i have it on my bookshelf
it's just a tiny little book but it's
basically like you know you put it you
look up your um symptom and then it
gives you a suggestion and i hate it
every time i'm like
and louise is a friend of mine before
she passed it was so sad but it's from
the grave i'm like goddamn by the way
like ah you're so right you know stop it
you know
it's so simple right i mean like life
generally i mean i've said this a few
times lately i tend to
repeat a thought in my head until it's
been vetted out until i come to some
sort of conclusion on it but um that
life is life is like really simple
because it's kind of all information
about ourselves that's right everything
through everything
through everything and so but yet it's
complicated because we can't see
ourselves yes so it's kind of like my
friend said um her and her daughter were
having a conversation she's like her
daughter's really pretty spiritual for
her age for sure she's just like 12. um
but she was talking to her daughter
about insecurity and she goes mom she's
like
you don't you can't you can't see
yourself in 3d
you don't know how you move and how you
look and she's like you only see
yourself in 2d and i'm like oh my god
that's so roofy and like found
right you never like we never see
ourselves in 3d to know how we navigate
the world and how we look and how we
feel and you know so um
anyway is that it's all information
about us and that we need other people
in other situations call it a dis-ease
call it a person a relationship a
promotion a firing a breakup whatever it
is true love we need all these things to
see ourselves because we can't see
ourselves like it has to continue to be
reflected back through all these other
mediums yeah a hundred percent and i
think i think the beauty in it you know
one of the because i i
i think one of my favorite topics to
talk about is relationships because
they're so um
complicated and funny if you look at it
a certain way but also so painful and
awful but also so beautiful and amazing
um and i think one of the biggest
misnomers is that people think that you
know for example in a relationship i
just heard this with a client like the
other day you know um
they were dating this woman was dating
this guy and they were getting closer
and closer and closer and taking their
time and then they you know slept
together and then he like had to freak
out and was like oh my god i just
realized all this stuff is coming up and
i have to go do the work on my own
and i'm like amateur move nope that's
not how it works because the purpose of
relationship like you get traumatizing
relationship
it's the vessel for healing too right
you don't heal on your own so this whole
idea to love myself before i get into a
relationship is nonsense avoidant
[ __ ] right oh my god preach and rip
go on a tangent i'm ready for it i'm
here because yeah because the healing is
through the relationship right it's
through the relationship and so that
i've said this a bunch i think it's so
important you know obviously what's the
purpose of relationship well
in in in evolutionary biology it's
obviously procreation and safety in
numbers right for mammals we get along
in numbers right and then you talk about
okay
then we're gonna like maybe help each
other like amplify our purpose and like
each of us will have a bigger future
together right cool awesome
um okay romance cool passion cool check
awesome we got all the good stuff maybe
uh shared financial burdens cool awesome
right great awesome
but the real juice in a relationship is
twofold one is to be a caretaker and i
use that word intentionally if you don't
like the fact that i'm using this word
because some people look like caretaker
oh my god
look up the definition before you go
further okay
to become a caretaker of each other's
traumatic parts right that is a not the
therapist not a mom not a dad but to
understand at like a very profound level
what someone's pain is like what is
their pain
and then to intentionally do [ __ ] to
help that not happen and to like help to
like make it better for that person in
that area and to have that be mutually
reciprocal so some people will say to me
mastin that's crazy i do that but i'm in
the relationship with a narcissist and
they don't do that i'm like no you're
not getting it it has to be reciprocal
right it can't just be one way okay so
if you by the way if you know that
you're in a relationship with a
narcissist
what's your part in that get out of that
relationship okay like knock it off like
get out right
um but it's about having mutually
reciprocal regulations so that the
relationship becomes a place to regulate
and to feel better rather than a place
to escape from and avoid right it's like
the opposite of what we've been taught
so is this co-regulation versus
codependency yes exactly yes thank you
for saying that that's so accurately
clinical so i love that that's beautiful
they're your words my friend i know but
okay that's true okay but you said it
and okay yeah you said it and that's
really good
you just mirrored me which is beautiful
so that maybe that's why i liked it so
much but but so here's the second part
okay and so like one you want to
understand like okay this is this
person's trauma here's the things that
help them regulate and vice versa and
i'm feeling reciprocation here but the
second part and this is the hard part
okay and i think if i was like a
guardian angel
like i would set life up this way just
to be entertained by like the reality
show called earth right like because
there's just so many things happening
and it's just like that is what's
happening i think by the way it's just
like oh let's just
keeping up with earth let's just see how
it's going down there right i imagine
that there's people up there with
popcorn totally oh can you believe that
oh an idiot you know yeah totally so
silly they don't see it yeah totally
totally
so so so this is what i think keeps the
guardian angels amused right is is um
most people um will say we shouldn't be
together because we want different
things
right and that
danica is an also an amateur move okay
the reason why you shouldn't be together
is because you don't know how to do
different things
together
and there's a big difference because
it's the things we have in common that
attract us to each other and it's our
differences that grow us
right um and so knowing how to be
different and together is like the
master skill
in relationship and it is so
hard because the way the world works is
we pull in our mirror who has something
that we're missing
and that initially makes it very
exciting for us
but over time it will disregulate us
because it starts to repeat old patterns
unless we learn differentiation which is
how can i be my full self and my
different self and really embody what
i'm learning from this other person
into my own being so that they're
they're a place where i can go to
regulate a place where i go to be safe
and awesome but i have my own life my
own boundaries my own purpose and we are
different together and the key skill set
in that
is knowing how to navigate the tension
of being different
and most people have no clue how to do
that because all these automatic
patterns are coming up um and
it is beautiful on the other side of
that kind of um
that kind of growth because you know you
resolve things from childhood you
amplify your purpose but then you can
like be your own self and neither party
has to collapse because usually if one
party takes up all the space another
party that's kind of collapsing in a
relationship right and the i most ideal
relationship is both parties are like
the light both parties it's kind of like
in chemistry they're called eczemas
noble gases where they're balanced right
they're not trying to attract a negative
or positive like you know negative and
positive come together noble gases or
eczema are completely balanced and they
don't attract negatives or positive
because they're balanced and the only
way for like a noble gas like neon to be
able to merge another noble gas is they
have to become light together right
which is why neon signs light up right
because they're temporarily emerging
so to me it's like an eczema vibe where
it's like for us to actually be together
we both have to step into our light
that's beautiful well yeah i think so
too right i want like art made out of
that yeah totally needs to become art
yeah i'm actually gonna get here
regulate uh neon sign which is kind of
cheesy but because it's like what it
means beneath what it says it's gonna
say manifesting magic but it's neon and
the neon represents kind of eczemas
which is like basically two balanced
beings coming together to make light
which i think is like so cool you know
oh cool and they have to be like that's
beautiful okay so i have a couple
questions around that so in relationship
that's funny i didn't think we go in the
relationship direction oh i love timeout
relationships love it um i mean that's
where the most of the dysregulation
shows up i mean so it's it's our deepest
most vulnerable spaces so it's really
like it's where we squeeze the most is
where we take things the most personally
it's where we're the most triggered and
we just generally spend the most time
there that's right
so yes so
i'm fascinated by the idea of like how
um like so
when you attract a partner and
you
i've heard
that it's your initial
feeling with that person the initial
chemistry or connection
that tends to be the indicator of your
uh compatibility
and that it's
over time lost to things like you just
spoke about
but that initial
is is as a big indicator is do you have
you heard anything about that do you
know anything about that does that make
sense or is that just not true well
uh such a great question um it's great
and also a great zone because um
for example
i work with mostly women okay so just so
we're really clear from a diverse
background six foot five white guy from
kansas dupont family history okay
working with diverse groups of women of
all colors and sexual orientations right
so who am i to talk i just have data
sets that's all i'm talking about right
um what i know and i know this like i
know like i know like i know okay is
that female whether or not you identify
as one but just your neuroanatomy as
being born a female okay
female intuition is so
dialed okay it is so dialed when i work
with my heterosexual male clients i'm
like all right guys here's the deal
you need to behave
as if
everything you're doing she knows
exactly what you're doing
because she does okay you just
let's just start with that assumption
okay let's just start right there and it
like kind of blows their mind um and
somebody oh my god you're so right right
so
i think if you're able to be in a
regulated state because a lot of times
you meet someone there's butterflies
there's like sexual stuff happening
there's so many things that's happening
or flirting when do i text when am i not
texting all this stuff that's happening
right it's all like confusing and you
get very like heady and like when should
i text and do i do an emoji or not i
don't like all that stuff starts to
happen right
uh how long do i wait should i wait
is it too much is it not enough like all
that stuff you're not paying attention
to what your intuition is saying
right um and so the women that i've
worked with doesn't matter how they
identify in terms of their sexual
identity or expression or preference um
when we get into things like betrayal or
relationships not working out and we go
back and we get really still your
initial intuitive hit
is spot on
spot on now that's probably true for
most guys too our intuition's a little
bit more sort of i don't know blunted um
we're a little bit more you know i mean
we definitely have intuition but it's
just not as like refined as uh female
intuition
um it's just how it just that's just
that's just how it works in their
anatomy um so but the problem is that
you get all this other stuff that starts
to come up that's a very powerful
biochemistry so you might have a for
example a first impression where your
biochemistry is like this guy's just
like my abusive father it feels like
home but your intuition's like nah girl
this is toxic
shut up trump we're gonna we're gonna
move forward right because we're gonna
this is exciting and fun or whatever
right so when you talk about your
initial impression right it's like what
part of we are you are we talking about
right if we're talking about butterflies
and biochemistry you know um that's not
an indicator of long-term relationship
health like just because you have good
chemistry doesn't mean anything because
good chemistry is not what creates a
long-term relationship you can build a
good chemistry over time
because if you have a friendship first
if you have an emotional connection
first if you have emotional safety first
you can learn what other people the
person needs in terms of whatever their
buttons are that pushes their chemistry
a certain way
and sometimes initial chemistry can just
be like an automatic failure trauma
response from the past and sometimes
it's very healthy right so there's no
like right or wrong answer but what you
want to try to get at instead of like
what i tell people when it comes to
dating right it's like
if you're interested in someone or
pursuing somebody or you're kind of in
that in between phase
you don't make a move i don't care one
day two day three day 10 days however
long whatever the dating ex who cares
about dating experts and all that who
cares until you're in a state where you
feel clear about what you're gonna do
and you're not operating from like oh my
god i need to respond or
butterflies right or any of that stuff
right
until you're like really clear on like
what you want to say and like it's
coming from like a really solid place do
not respond
okay like slow it down right what's the
rush right and i actually think it's
important in new relationships to like
have that magnetism happen where you
slow things down because a lot of times
it can be a trauma response to rush into
relationship too fast and not pay
attention to the signals that your
body's giving you
right
um especially when it comes to women
because you know women traditionally
haven't been treated too good by the
patriarchy so they've learned over time
women have learned over time that like
what they're feeling and thinking is not
important doesn't matter and isn't true
when it's super important really matters
and is spot on
right
um and so yeah i mean i i i it's a
little bit more nuanced than what you
said and i hope that was helpful or
maybe it was too long oh that was
incredible as again every answer is
incredible
um
i want to go more into a little bit of
part of that but before before i get
there i want to ask about
you know it feels like there's a
possibility that you could kind of you
know as abraham hicks would say you
could essentially put your attention on
anything positive about somebody and
make them the right person right like oh
for sure yeah you can use anyone as your
reason for happiness
um based on what you put your
perspective put your attention on um so
are there generally though given the
fact that we have we are attracting
mirrors to see things about ourselves to
heal
are there people
that are meant to be temporary or
transitory as opposed to
forever like is that is that part of the
journey of being a human is going
through
it's it's like they serve a purpose you
serve a purpose for each other
um
and and then it's time to move on yeah i
100 i think like okay so real quick by
the way i love the law of attraction i
have asking is given i've read it a
million times
um and when we look through the lens of
and basically law of attraction is just
goal setting is basically what it is i
mean basically right and it's combined
with emotional state focus which is
important
um
but when we talk about attraction like
we're attracting things i like to say
okay let's pause on the word attraction
because attracting is like takes away
your agency like i had no partner i just
attracted it and what happened the
universe just attracted it right i like
to replace attracting with choosing
because you have a part in it right you
can attract something and say no
right um and that's important understand
so so i like to kind of put the word
choosing in there when it comes to what
you're talking about like transitional
relationships yeah i absolutely think
especially if you've been like in a
long-term intense relationship right and
then you break up um and you have
someone who's there for you either
platonically
as a friend
or as something even as a romantic
partner and you might even know they're
not the right person
right but you know that like right now
it's
more dysregulating for me to be alone so
i'm going to kind of have this as like a
methadone right to kind of come off this
and kind of have it be like a step down
totally that is something that can
happen and it's completely healthy
absolutely yes yeah the only thing i
will tell you is this okay
um
because i understand neurochemistry
right when a woman
okay when a woman has sex and it could
be with a man or fame or woman doesn't
matter okay when a woman has sex so much
oxytocin is released okay and oxytocin
bonds can last up to two to three years
with somebody okay
um and so
it's not that you shouldn't have sex
with somebody if you're a woman i'm not
saying that at all you're you can be as
empowered as you want to be
sexually and there's no judgment around
that i have zero judgment around it i
think the more sexually empowered a
woman is the better i think it's super
healthy to success expressed sexually
and you just have to understand what's
happening biochemically in your body
when certain things happen and
unfortunately uh the evolutionary
biology for female if you look at the in
traditional evolution evolution right
the biological purpose of a female is to
produce one child per year
right so like the female body is wired
to bond more intensely than the male
body which is wired to procreate
all over the place right like because we
want because we lived in times where
your kids may not live right so like
there's a there's a purpose there of why
we're wired differently so the
biochemical consequences
of a woman sleeping with someone is just
different than the way that a man is
when they sleep with someone so if
you're willing to take the risk and live
the consequence then that's all good too
but and again it's not judgment i'm just
giving you biochemistry right so that
someone can make an active choice and my
typical rule is my rule that i advise my
clients if you're looking for a good
time or a transitory time then like be
free with yourself just understand
what's happening in your body and be
willing to take the risks
because it will feel like you're coming
off a drug if it stops okay just like if
you go on a sugar binge you're gonna
have you're gonna have like that or
heroin binge or whatever you alter your
biochemistry in a big way you're gonna
have a withdrawal phase
but if you're looking for a soulmate
right if you're looking for a person
who's like your person my suggestion and
i get i get i get backlash for this
because it seems like old school
patriarchal but it's not it's actually
biochemical
is do not have sex with someone
until you have a monogamous commitment
if if you're looking for a soulmate
right because there's so much that gets
you talk about like not missing like
missing your body signals there's so
much to get confused when like you just
have the rush of oxytocin dopamine
neurone epinephrine all the dopamine all
the stuff just starts to kind of go
crazy right
um you can really miss a lot of signals
and it hap and those bonding chemicals
are just more intense for the female
body than the male body based on
evolutionary biology this is not 1950s
i'm not trying to make it some like old
school thing it's just the scientific
data right um and so that's what i
typically advise my clients um and
sometimes it can feel good to have
someone that was your intense
relationship
that you want to be with that person for
a few months or a year or whatever as
you kind of come off and maybe both of
you know it's not gonna be a long-term
thing and
when it stops there will be withdrawal
so just know that that i don't that
answers your question but
that's
that's
what that's what the biochemistry says
hmm well i think this is a good way to
pull it back into the body and go into
the you know your famous line the issues
are in the tissues
and the fascia and you know everything
from like
massage somatic some i've had somatic
experiences within massage using audible
just sounds um too like i was fascinated
to hear about you talk about how there's
a somatic response in rem sleep
that's fascinating um acupuncture
all these things like i think you know
explaining taking a trauma and then
going down the line of the of the path
of the trauma to manifest in to the body
and like how what actually is going on
a phys on a physical level yeah what
you're describing right are three of my
favorite words mechanisms of action
right
those are my three favorite words
because mechanisms of action if you just
google cancer quotes mechanisms of
action or whatever in quotes mechanisms
action
you're going to pull up a lot of data
that basically shows you
what happens physiologically in the body
when certain things happen right so like
what's the mechanism of actions for a
drug or for a disease or for whatever
and i spend a lot of time focused on
mechanisms because
i like to understand what's happening
but at the end of the day like you said
you have to have the experience of it
you have to embody it but there ha i do
believe there should be some
psychoeducation and cognitive awareness
around the mechanisms because when you
understand the mechanisms in your body
it also de-shames the process because a
lot of people take on the identity of
shame and you know if they get even if
they get like a diagnosis they're like
oh my god i am ptsd not i have it right
that goes becomes their identity versus
like well
actually you had uh chronic neglect
growing up which oriented your nervous
system this way and then you went
through this specific adverse event and
then because of that because you entered
into it with a certain belief about
yourself it reinforced that belief on a
very important level and then you
created this like fractured 14 year old
part of yourself that lives in your gut
and it was so painful that up you
basically protected yourself from that
part so even though it's there and then
then that part was like running the show
and then all these things didn't happen
as a result of that and you know you
chose these relationships and this type
of food and these types of places to be
in and you know 30 years later here we
are
right um that's not really an identity
that's just like look how resilient you
are to get through all that and like if
we can understand all those mechanisms
and start to have corrective action
you know we can make it better but i
think one of the biggest i don't know
issues with and it's not that it's not
mental healthcare's fault but people
take and i i diagnosis and create an
identity out of it um and that is not a
good idea right
but what you just said is so true
because there are so many things that
happen
when trauma happens but the thing that's
most interesting
is that
if a trauma happens
whether someone has post-traumatic
growth or post-traumatic stress
is determined by what was the quality of
their relationships and nervous system
going into the event and then what was
the quality of the relationships and
nervous system after the event
right so if something was swept under
the rug
you're gonna have a very different
response than if it was embraced
discussed and loved and cared for
right um and so yeah i mean and there's
so much that happens in the body with
the immune system and the nervous system
and i mean the endocrine system there's
so many things that start to happen
depending what happens in the
environment
right and in our relationships and it
absolutely is in the body you know i've
had so many clients
when we get into fascial work like i've
watched them like i watch their fascia
and i watch them move and they literally
recreate the positions that traumatize
them like in front of me we do this all
the time
the difference is they're able to have a
completion where they can say stop or
they're able to get up and they're able
to move they're able to ha do something
different because the fascia doesn't
want you to go back into the same
position that traumatized you right and
so it tries to get you to never go to
that position again but if you can go
back to that position and then break
that pattern safely you can have a lot
of amazing changes because the fascia is
super smart and super wise it
communicates faster than the nervous
system
but um yeah there's a lot of mechanisms
in there there's so many mechanisms
what about the cells i'm i'm always
fascinated to you know
have this sort of belief or unders or
you know
growing understanding for
uh trauma on a cellular level ancestral
ancestral trauma
in the cells and please explain that
because yeah
well it makes it it's like it's an
invisible passenger right like how do i
know what happened what i mean but
things can be holding you back and
and so if this is a real thing now all
of a sudden this becomes a checklist of
what do we where do i go to find a
solution if this becomes a more common
understanding definitely yeah um so like
if you think if you just let's just
let's just like
there's so much data to back up what you
just said but let's just think common
sense for a second okay
like
evolution is the
continuing process of pattern
recognition being turned into dna and
cellular information over time
right because
we're experiencing more and more
of data of what's happening in the world
and then that orients into our
epigenetic expression which is how our
body uniquely expresses its genes right
and then in the reproductive process
there's a whole field of psychology
called perinatal psychology which is
like in the womb psychology
you know the baby is being bathed in all
kinds of information about the
environment it's about to be born into
right so that when it comes out it's
like prepared to survive that makes a
ton of sense right and then if you had
on top of that this is always
mind-blowing
the egg that you were made from in your
mother's womb
was made in her mother's womb
so like you're kind of your grandmother
in a way right which is like so trippy
to think about right so like not only
does epigenetic information get passed
down from one generation to the next so
that we can better navigate the
environment
but like literally like part of you was
like
two generations ago right fractal
totally everything in the universe
fractal i'm beginning it's just all
freaking fractal i interviewed nassim
and um we talked about fractals and it's
just like the most fascinating thing
between
this realm of conversation and science
and quantum science and physics is like
my jam
yeah well quantum is if you think about
quantum for a second right like quantum
um so like okay we'll go there for a
second i don't want to go i don't want
to get off topic no because it's it's
it's
related it's related right so like if
you think about um like traumatic memory
right or if you think about traumatic or
emotional or just any emotional state
whether it's traumatic or not right
i'm getting to a point this is me this
is me hypothesizing okay this is not
like data
i'm starting to believe that like
traumatic memory
and emotions of all kinds are actually
fields just like you have a
gravitational field or you have a
electromagnetic field right i believe
there's like an emotional field um and
that field uh impacts your physiology
right and then it that impacts the
physiology of the people around you and
so that's why like generational trauma
can get kind of passed down because
you're basically vibrating together in a
certain field and that's why when you go
on a healing journey you feel like
you're going to be abandoned because
you're creating this whole new energy
pattern
right
the problem with a lot of the quantum
approaches and by the way i have so much
respect for dr joe dispenza's work he
doesn't understand trauma he tries to
make you have an emotion that's greater
than the trauma emotion which is not
really the goal we want to like embrace
it befriend it and then we can go to
elevated states
but his work is genius he just it if it
was trauma informed
he totally steps over that yeah and he
doesn't have by the way he doesn't have
to be trauma informed right but but his
work like when you go quantum like with
his work right you're trying to create
these new fields in your body you're
trying to create this new body this new
emotional state right the problem is is
that the survival because he's like even
in some of his meditations he starts at
the heart and goes up i'm like what
about one two and three you know like
what about the survival stuff right it's
a one four and seven a lot of i mean i
went to a week-long joe dispenza retreat
last year or yeah at the beginning of
this year last year and um
you know 100 there's there's chakras
that are missed like it's just
it's just bouncing yeah that's by the
way i'm not dodging it or dissing him i
have tremendous respect for him just
like tony robbins tony robbins isn't
trauma informed either right but what he
does is genius right
um
and so like the idea is is that like
these these survival fields these trauma
fields are way more powerful than like
you know trying to go quantum and i've
had clients who have you know gone to
places like that gone super expansive
but their survival response has pulled
them back into their body and they don't
know what to do with it right
um and it's literally like breaking up
the fascia breaking up the pattern but
most importantly befriending it and
actually like turning towards and going
hey like how's it going what are you all
about in there right
and learning more about those parts
because when we discount those parts
that's when the hard stuff starts to
happen um but but i believe that those
are all i believe it's all fields i
think it's all there's all
electromagnetic energy there 100 percent
um and it's very difficult to grow your
energy field when you're in a
dysregulated energy field that's another
way to put it um and i believe that
because we live in limited limitless
possibility that like you can have
incredible rapid uh integration from
trauma and we're seeing that now with
like the psycho the mdma map studies and
stuff like that like people are
integrating at really beautiful levels
but it's because they're befriending
their trauma not because they're trying
to grow bigger than it right like that
there's a big difference in those in
that in that distinction right there
well i feel like one is
you know going into the trauma and
looking at it
talking to it alchemizing it is the
feeling is the
is the is the getting to the root and
and and pulling it out by the root or
alchemizing the event um and i think
other forms if you skip over that it
doesn't mean you don't feel better it
just means that there's a chance that
you might not feel good again this is
very nuanced i think this is the thing
it's like the word like worse you know
especially you speaking a language that
that's why i had you describe the word
trauma just because it until you've been
into this work long enough you hear
trauma and you're like i don't have
trauma
like i don't know how many people i talk
to like close to me that would you know
say it's like nothing's wrong with me i
don't have anything wrong i don't need
to see a therapist i'm like
oh my god everybody has so true
i would just you know my favorite thing
to do with things like that is start
with symptoms it's like do you have
depression anxiety insecurity
perfectionism procrastination self doubt
uh add
uh dramatic relationships you know like
do you have a hard time being alone
right like if we go down that list you
have a hard time achieving goals like do
you put yourself aside like it's
sometimes good when people when the
problem is not understood right is to
start with symptoms and then go the
likelihood that that's a trauma response
is very high
right um and so i like to start with
symptoms first a lot of times because
you know yeah people i don't have trauma
and they're right they don't maybe they
don't have uh wartime ptsd or they
didn't have some type of you know abuse
in their history a lot of people did but
some people some people don't right but
doesn't mean there's not trauma there
right it's just it is very nuanced um
and it's even more nuanced when you
start talking about like what's your
skin color what's your sexual identity
what's your orientation
um you know and and like what are your
biases based on like my white body color
and stuff like that how i see the world
like race was never an issue for me and
my privilege like it gets so nuanced the
more that you get into it and the issue
that i have with a lot of the ways that
the trauma informed conversations are
emerging
is that there's this expectation of
perfectionism
to like get it right like to be the
right white ally or to be the right type
of you know uh whatever right and like
the truth is about racism is that it is
a cancer that needs to be eradicated
from the world but we have not solved
the problem in 400 years okay it is not
solved and so
i think that what's important right now
when we talk about a trauma-informed
approach is to make it a discussion
where there's room for questions and
messing up and not understanding and
learning about
each other's perspectives and the
problem i have with like really extreme
cancer culture is that it actually
negates the very evolution they're
trying to produce
and with what they value because you
know um
it's not something that uh includes a
conversation it's like i need you to do
it in this very specific way
that i have not actually defined in any
way that could be followed and if you
don't do it then i'm going to cancel you
right and that approach is not an
approach that will be effective it might
feel empowering in the moment it might
feel like you have agency in the moment
but it won't create long-term change um
and so it's very important understand
that like racism me too consent uh go
down the list of the important social
justice issues
when you take a trauma-informed approach
everything becomes so nuanced
and complex like you wouldn't believe
right um and so i think it's so
important to have the conversation to
slow the conversation down to be as
curious as you can and to for sure
understand and especially someone like
me like i'm gonna mess up like i'm not
gonna be the best white ally at times
i'm not going to be the best indigenous
ally at times i'm not going to be the
best ally for the gay community or
lgbtqi plus community at times right i'm
not going to get all the nuances all the
time and yeah why because i'm white and
i have whiteness
right and i don't know right but
demonizing that and demonizing someone
who's trying to try it you could call it
white fragility i think everyone has a
sensitivity to it nobody wants to hurt
somebody else and yes there is white
fragility but i just think that the
perfectionism of how
advocacy is supposed to happen the
expectation of that negates the outcome
right whether it's a social justice
issue or whether it's trying to talk
about trauma because the last thing i'll
do in a relationship is say well that's
just your trauma talking
right like it's it's it's it's it's we
have to have a completely different type
of conversation when it comes to taking
a trauma form approach and it requires a
lot more exhaling a slower breath and a
calmer yeah i want you to
explain more i'm trying like what do you
mean to have a trauma-informed approach
to
a social dynamic or a situation other
than saying oh that's trauma that that
kind of is what comes to mind for me
like there's just trauma so what do you
mean to have a trauma-informed approach
sure so so look there's different types
of of human beings right so i'm not
talking about
um you know i'm not talking about like
george floyd doing something differently
right like what happened to him is
[ __ ] up awful
and it's unfortunately being repeated so
many times okay
uh and it's it's it's disgusting and it
drives me nuts like what happened to dr
christine blasey ford at the brett
kavanaugh hearings was disgusting okay
it was awful um like
her stuff was so legit in terms of the
nature of traumatic memory how it works
and the fact they brought in a trauma
expert to discount that like just
made me want to vomit regardless of
political right so what we have to
understand is that
when you're in an adverse population and
you're don't have equity meaning you
don't have the same advantages of other
people and it's not equality you're not
treated the same way
it's unrealistic to expect marginalized
populations who are
basically chronically dysregulated to
behave in regulated ways when they're
experiencing trauma after trauma after
trauma after trauma after trauma after
trauma okay it's not fair okay what i'm
talking about is the leaders of
uh social justice movements and the
leaders in the psychotherapy movements
and leaders in mental health who are
trauma-informed right who are guiding
the conversation in their various
different groups of different very
important
um social work right
we have to ask a question right me too
now what black lives matter now what
what's the now what and to me to now
what is let's break the cycle
let's break the cycle right nuts like
yes black lives matter yes that's yes
100 it needs to be said it should never
not be said but like the elevated vision
is how the [ __ ] do we make it stop
right and it's like that's called cycle
breaking and cycle breaking is so
nuanced danica it is so nuanced and so
difficult because it involves everybody
right
behaving differently eventually and so
um we have to start to understand that
there is whiteness there is white
privilege we got to do our white body
work we got to understand all the
patriarchal stuff we always have to
understand colonialism and all those
things
and those have to be acknowledged and
we're making actually really good
progress right now with reparations and
this current administration which is
like so cool to have that start to
happen um and what i know regardless of
what group of people you happen to
identify with or what your skin color is
we all have the same type of nervous
system and
the nervous system doesn't know when the
war is over when the war is over right
like just look at all the veterans that
come back from war right so what does
cycle breaking look like right
and like i don't have the answer to that
but what i know is is that the leaders
of the groups
uh who there should be a higher
expectation of right because they're the
leader right of whatever the group is
we need to collectively come up with a
new map for how to stop this [ __ ]
um and yes acknowledgement of the trauma
is so important like for someone to be
able to say me too
like whenever somebody comes out and
says i'm a survivor like that is a
heroic
incredible powerful important moment to
have your trauma validated right um when
you like say who's ever is unfortunately
the name of the day of someone who's
being killed today by police
their names should never be stopped
being said right
but we also want to look at how the [ __ ]
do we make it stop right and i don't
have the answer but i know it's nuanced
and what i know for sure is if you look
at the work of dr bruce perry
he talks about you need to do it in this
order any any relationship you have to
regulate your nervous system
first then you have to build a
relationship
and then you reason
with your build a relationship with your
body
with yourself but with the other person
with the other person too okay right so
you regulate make sure you come into a
right you're in a regulated state
then you build a relationship both from
a regulated state and then you reason
you could use executive function to like
figure stuff out right in that order but
if you go straight to reason but you're
dysregulated and don't have a good
relationship nothing's going to happen
right it's going to be the perpetual
cycle process right
and so like again i don't i'm not
claiming to have answers i'm just
reporting on neuroscience and talking
about how new ones these topics are um
but i would like to see the conversation
evolve into
like
me too being a catalyst for it to
[ __ ] stop right not just let's
continue power dynamics with the
different terms in hollywood now or
whatever right and like for black lives
matter to end
police violence right like that's what
has to happen right we want to stop
this nonsense and it's like well what
has to happen for that to happen i don't
know but i know if we can regulate and
co-regulate then we can build
relationship and have dignity in those
relationships and then we can make some
really good choices right that's how the
nervous system works and that's like
neurosequential sequencing dr bruce
perry just wrote a book with oprah about
trauma like he knows what he's talking
about right um
and and that would be the approach and
it's so nuanced because here's the thing
because we're solving starting to you
know solve this problem more explicitly
now there's like new patterns and new
things that we're going to identify that
we didn't know like jessica man who's a
client of mine who's an incredible human
being and she's let me talk about
publicly she was on trial with harvey
weinstein for three days
and it's her testimony that put him
behind bars
okay and she came to me to work on
trauma afterwards and it was like an
honor of my lifetime to work with her
but
she is such a powerful soul
and the reason why harvey weinstein is
behind bars is because jessica
however i still don't understand okay
was able to stay regulated and be so
articulate in describing the nuance of
their power dynamics that she actually
created new case law in new york state
defining a new type of predator
right and so like that didn't happen
before jessica man now after jessica man
there's this whole new definition of
something so that is going to continue
to happen
as we have more nuanced conversations
about things like power dynamics between
you know consent and sex and
power and money and stuff like that
relationships racism all the different
things there's gonna be a whole new
vocabulary that we get to create
together right it doesn't exist yet it
doesn't exist
it makes me as you were talking about
like creating these social dynamics and
and patterns and culture that are that
that need to need to change like how do
we actually change something it makes me
want to ask if you think that because i
mean you know there are quotes from
famous people that are if you want to
change a system you don't try and fix
the old one you start a new one sure and
i think i mean that's bucky fuller love
bucky fuller right bucky fuller said the
way to change the system is you don't
argue with it you make a new system that
makes the old system obsolete and i
would start with your nervous system
right like like that's the system i
would start i was an inside job master
it is yeah because it's like anything in
life right i don't care what it is it's
about your approach
right like like think about it right
think about it right like i coach guys
on like how to flirt without being me
too basically and it's very simple right
it's so simple it's your approach
right and here it is if you're in a
heterosexual guy looking for a
heterosexual relationship and you're
worried about all that stuff don't touch
her first let her touch you first
tell her what you're thinking and
feeling don't just behave on it like
have an explicit conversation about
what's happening inside your body right
that's a change in your approach and
amazingly women are receptive to that
most of the time right i want you to
write a book called how to be a man
okay all right there's good men out
there they're definitely good absolutely
but i think but it's like the the
there's there almost needs to be a new
book for it for sure but i think there's
a lot of guys who are really amazing who
are scared to
engage because like they're like what's
the difference between sexual misconduct
and flirting right it's like well that's
by the way when was that question asked
before like we've never asked that
question before it's so good that we're
asking that question right right and in
fact it's the ones that are actually
aware that they don't want to screw up
that probably aren't going to screw up
yeah that's true
yeah it's so true but but there needs to
be a step-by-step process right and
that's what i mean is that like what's
the difference between flirting and
sexual misconduct like cool like let's
define that like how do we define the
racial gaps in our country by the way
there's a different experience i have
clients that are like uh
african-american black who are like
black like they're black clients right
then i have like mixed clients
who are partially white partially black
so they have lighter skin tone they have
a completely different experience if
you're mixed then if you're black versus
if you're white right and so like
the when did we have these nuanced
conversations right because i've had
clients of mine who are mixed and
they're not quite black enough for their
black friends and they're not quite
white enough for their white friends so
there's a whole other conversation right
so to me it's like how the hell are we
gonna figure out all this stuff
ahead of time before we get into the
messy conversation to make this whole
new vocabulary come through right
emotional regulation
exactly right it's it's you gotta have a
regulated approach right and that's very
difficult because we haven't solved
these problems like i said like 400
years so is this what you would say in
using more of your words because again i
know your work um the difference between
emotional intelligence and emotional
fitness
yes that's so good that you love yes
exactly yes
yes
yeah i love that so cool um yeah so
emotional intelligence is just you know
understanding what to do it's more
cognitive right emotional fitness is
like the embodiment of it and by the way
just so we're clear we're talking about
some of the hardest stuff in the world
right like solving racism solving
patriarchy solving colonialism
differentiating in relationships like
this is like some of the hardest
problems like you can get to mars easier
than you can do these things okay
literally okay because we've already
gone to mars right
exactly by the way dear elon musk please
do not send anybody with unresolved
trauma to another planet let's not
spread human trauma to make that
interplanetary we'd have some type of
like litmus test for like who can leave
planet [ __ ] you know that's not possible
madison because they won't be human then
because every human's got it he's gotta
send dogs or something um
yeah so so but their needs the regulated
nervous system is really what it's about
and that's really about being seen and
known and heard and it's a skill set
that we're learning and it's a whole new
like to me what we're talking about is
the social justice and mental health
like what einstein was the physics like
it's a quantum leap literally right
because it's a whole new approach to
understanding things um and i know a lot
of really well-intended white people
they're terrified to even like support
black lives matter not because they're
gonna get [ __ ] about it from their white
friends but because they don't want to
seem performative but like guys like
let's just help let me just see that
just like get in the conversation like
let's get in the conversation like don't
let the fear of cancel
move on like like stop you like let's
get in the conversation let's make it
happen you want to say the wrong thing
so sometimes you just don't say anything
at all you know
exactly and i think that like that's the
part that i want to bust up because it's
like in a relationship right like saying
nothing is sometimes the worst thing to
do like at least you're trying to
attempt connection totally right um and
by the way i have by the way i have
stepped on my pale i'm not sure what to
say how i put it so many times your dick
yeah okay
yeah okay great that might be funny
okay yeah i've said that my dick many
times when it comes to these types of
things um but i get back up i learn i go
cool let's let's change the approach
right um and that's how i learn this is
how we learn so yeah these conversations
are intensely nuanced and there is not a
vocabulary for them yet which is why i
think they're so complex and so
difficult because people don't even
understand the problem and we can't even
have a conversation about the problem
without it being this cancer culture
situation so it's like
where do we go like it's not it's not
like it's not really solvable in those
conditions which is why i think to your
earlier point about bucky fuller like
the system that has to change is our
nervous system and our approach to
things has to rapidly change and i think
we'll get majorly different results for
sure
how do we know you know one of the
things i'd like to ask about because it
kind of gets into a little bit of like
emotional intelligence
um awareness
feeling your true feelings is is this
nuanced difference between feeling
between
um
a true intuition
and something that is
um
uh
a trigger like of a trauma you know
because like
there's a there's so i i still don't
have i'm not great at it but i mean
the difference between the intuition and
sort of the trigger the trauma i mean i
don't know you well but i think you're
probably doing better than you're giving
yourself credit for it be my guess
because you've done some pretty awesome
stuff in your life and i'm sure a lot of
it's been intuitive you might guess
um but it sounds like what you want to
do because you're obviously into high
performance you want to get better at it
but i don't i don't know if you're not
good at it i don't know if i would if i
could let it go that far uh if i may be
so bold um
but um like i was talking with leanne
rimes like two weeks ago
and uh she's amazing and she was like
she was like yeah just like in like the
last like two years i feel like i'm
stepping in my purpose i was like whoa
slow down girl like
you're leann rhymes like you're an icon
and like in the last two years
you started to step in your purpose like
can we just like pause on that and
acknowledge how epic that is like holy
cow what have you been doing this whole
time like oh my god i can't even imagine
what's next
right um it's just i think pausing on
some of those moments sometimes can be
very powerful and very important
and my hunch is that you have really
good finely tuned intuitive skills but
what i can tell you is
that um
like let's just practice for a second
right has there ever been a time in your
life where you had this very clear yes
that like yes this is what i'm supposed
to do
and like it's like so clear to me
okay and do you know what that feels
like in your body
clear
yeah okay and then have you ever had a
time where it's such a obvious no you're
like
oh no that is not for me
yeah okay and you know what that feels
like
mm-hmm so
yeah so that's the baseline right you
want to start there like you already
know what it feels like to have a yes
and a no right
then it's about understanding this is
that this is the hard part when you're
making intuitive first of all people say
i want to be more intuitive it's like
no
you want different intuition
because like no they want they want to
intuit something differently meaning
like they don't like the intuition that
they're getting they want to be a
different intuition because everybody's
interesting problem is that your
intuition sometimes goes ooh shiny
things go there and you're like that
feels so good and then it's like oh
intuition's like get out of that
relationship or like quit that job and
you're like whoa i mean that's probably
not true i probably just need to try
harder
whatever like you go to that that
intuition yeah but but intuition is not
discretionary between like what you
think you what you as you're like the
place in this world is right now what
you want it's more about the long game
right so definitely your higher self and
your you know potentiality in a way that
you could never understand and so you
know the no's are just as progressive
just as great as oh definitely 100 and
like here's the thing and uh i don't
know if i have any data on this that i
can cite so i'm just gonna have to tell
you this is anecdotal
but what i've seen in my own life and
with our clients anecdotal okay it's
anecdotal meaning like for people what's
anecdotal it's just observed it's not
verified through peer-reviewed research
okay
um
when you
get enough interception meaning
awareness of your internal mechanisms
and all your emotions right and you
start to make contact with your most
traumatized parts and like start to like
love them and surface then make them
more explicit share them through a
relationship and they start to feel
better over time
on the other side of that part kind of
being i for lack of a word like pulled
out of purgatory right
like that is your direct connection to
spirit right there
right like that part is also your direct
connection to your intuition into spirit
and so what can feel like intuition can
sometimes be
a dissociated trauma response and like a
subtle underneath that is what the
intuition is but it can very very some
very similarly the part that's most
traumatized is usually the part that's
most sensitive to intuition to um and so
when you can help that part become more
explicit and more regulated
and then you start to listen to it
because that's the whole point of an
illness right as we were talking earlier
about is like to listen to your body
when you can actually listen to the part
that was
suicidal or super angry or depressed and
you can start to improve your
relationship with those parts and go
what are you what are you what are you
trying to tell me right now right
and then you're like oh i should leave
this relationship right and mine's like
kind of like right here on my left side
uh that's why i'm doing that right
that's where i feel it and this is also
the part that gets activated when i feel
super abandoned right i'm like all right
man what do you need right i need a hug
okay cool let's get a hug right um and
but the intuition is also right there
too um and so they can be very finely
married but at the same time if you can
anchor into like remembering what the
yes was and what the note was it can be
very helpful as well but
usually an intuitive choice
is
like co-occurring with
absolute fear
because it usually brings you more into
the mystery of life and less into the
certainty of life right
and so it can feel
very
um
i don't know strange in fact i just
relocated to los angeles and like this
field this felt like a crazy choice to
me for a long time i had to check in
with like
15 people
and i never overthink things right and i
was saying with my therapist who's like
was trained by milton erickson like
she's like top top top therapist she's
incredible and i was like
am i crazy am i can you please tell me
if i'm like bipolar or crazy or like
psychotic right now and she's like went
down the list she's like
no i think you're making a really good
choice and i was like but it feels awful
she's like actually mastin
usually you go so fast that you don't
feel your feelings right and you end up
maybe not making the best choice what
you're doing now is you're going slower
feeling your feelings
and it's actually a better choice
because you're so in touch with your
feelings and i was like wait wait wait
so what's wrong is right
and what's right is wrong she's like
basically right i was like oh my god i
hate this
i hate this so much right
so why is it why is it and i don't know
maybe you maybe you agree maybe you
don't but
i'm hearing discomfort for a decision
that you know is good for you or that
seems really like a smart one from
people around you
um
so in that kind of vein of thought is
like why is it that if we're going to
alchemize
a dynamic within us a pattern a hormone
regulation a hormone loop that we're in
why
it like
it
there's so much there's always pain
that's what i'm trying to say yeah sure
yeah hey but pain and suffering are
different they're different
they're different okay what's the
difference between pain and suffering
then so pain is like part of life right
um in fact a friend of mine sent me a
song recently called i think it's called
i wish you pain
by andy grammer um and it's actually an
amazing song because the whole idea is
that like it's the pain that helps you
grow right it's actually a really
triumphant beautiful song
um the first two times i listened to it
i was like this why'd you send this to
me like what are you trying to tell me
right i was like what you wish me pain
and i was like wait a minute master like
listen to these words i was like oh my
god this is so beautiful
suffering is long-term and it's like you
have an external locus of control
meaning your power is outside yourself
it's out there somewhere you don't have
the power internal pain is like i don't
know you're training and how do you get
stronger right well you have to create
micro trauma in the muscle that then
needs to go through a cat
sorry catabolic process right so you're
breaking down the muscle
then when you're sleeping you go through
an anabolic process of repair that then
turns those microtraumas into what
muscle fiber right um and so like that's
a painful process suffering is like you
ripped your you know your tendon or
something like that like you're not able
to perform anymore right
um and so pain is
unfortunately a necessary part of growth
it's kind of they go together for sure
but suffering is like living in
something that you don't need to live in
anymore because it's just like an old
pattern that has to die off and most of
the time when you're making an intuitive
decision
it's guiding you beyond the confines of
your wiring to a new future right like
we talked about with dispenza so you're
going to a new future but it's so
foreign to your nervous system that it's
scary because you've never been there
before right think about any goal that
you want to achieve i don't know most
people most people don't set goals that
they've already done
right
right they want a new goal so if you
want a new goal that means you're trying
to do something you've never done before
yeah it's gonna be scary
yeah
right that that's so yeah that mean does
that make sense
yeah yeah because there's always just
pain on that you know i mean it's the
pain
the pain of
letting go of a situation the pain of
never you know something not being the
same the pain of a new you know the pain
of new programming essentially
um but i always stress that to people
that you know if you're truly making
progress from an emotional state with
the things that are causing you sadness
or hurt or pain or whatever it may be or
suffering because suffering is from the
outside pain is on the inside but
suffering comes from the outside i guess
maybe like or less it's kind of like
it's kind of like pain is like a
required process for growth and change
just like i mean think about it right
like could you lift too much too hard
too heavy and hurt yourself yes right
but when you especially if you have a
friend never lift by yourself if you're
trying to do like you know to fatigue
right you obviously know that but like
that extra rep at that last rep right
where they just come on you can do it
they can give you [ __ ] or whatever i
don't know how you train but that's i
just love it when someone's like giving
me [ __ ] not like that last rep
that's where the growth is like right
there right now if you go too hard you
like snap your pec or something like no
that's not what we're talking about
suffering is like you're in a dynamic
that's like an old pattern that's not
growing you and it's just keeping you
stuck and you're safe but you're not
growing right to me that's what
suffering is it's it's not really growth
oriented and the thing about pain is
that the pain of growth doesn't last
forever it's temporary
right um and you know like i got i was
in so much pain last year um and like
today like i couldn't even i had to
crawl up the stairs last year took an
hour and a half to crawl up the stairs
um because like no one heard me so they
crawl it was so painful like today i'm
like jumping over fences and stuff like
that doing my pliability warm up stuff
like that no pain right because i was
able to change the system
um but suffering would just be like
staying in that state not learning the
lesson not doing the foster work not
paying attention to my emotions eating
shitty food like all that stuff right
that would be suffering so then what
would you have i mean we've talked about
so many juicy things so much
what is that like for someone listening
that's like
i'm interested what's the next step for
someone
um
i'm interested in my drama yeah well i
mean whenever but everyone everyone gets
there right yeah my my suggestion is a
couple things right is you know i mean i
would be self-promoting but i did write
a book on it because it gets asked so
many times i have a book called claim
your power um that's a 40-day kind of
almost like coaching process to kind of
help you go into all that it's very
powerful has awesome reviews it's you
know we're doing clinical pre-clinical
trial studies on the on the process now
so we can publish the findings and show
the efficacy
but there's other amazing books like you
could dive into
uh like for example uh uh internal
family systems just released a second
edition book that's an amazing book
on trauma you definitely
probably want to pick up the body keeps
the score by bessel van der kolk for
sure
those would be some good places to start
and then if you're wanting to work with
like trauma form practitioners obviously
we offer that but i would probably go to
either
like the ifs institute which is internal
family systems institute
or
somatic experiencing and their institute
and like find trauma-informed
practitioners who understand trauma if
you want to do the work we have courses
and programs and retreats all the time
first in may and of course in june right
yeah we have the may one is uh actually
a seven day retreat that's called the
root cause retreat that helps people
understand
how functional medicine and chronic
disease pair like functional coaching
and trauma work and then june is claim
your power live which is a three day
deep dive into your trauma and then into
your purpose and kind of like coming out
the other side really beautifully um
and you know i love my stuff obviously
but it's not for everybody um there's
also an incredible book
if you're looking more into like
understanding racial trauma called my
grandmother's hands um that is
phenomenal read no matter what your skin
color is um so like those would be some
places to start and you know um i would
also say that it's important to look at
your environment and your friends and
start to pick environments and friends
where you feel safe right to share about
more vulnerable things i think that's
really important too because without
that you'll feel very isolated and
isolation is a traumatizing experience
so don't traumatize yourself becoming
traumatic we're meant to be in community
that's right and this last year has been
tough but um
hopefully it points in the direction
even more so of how
similar we are than different and that
we require community
well that's why and i sent you a video
on this
that's why where i am right now in los
angeles it's called a regulate hq it's a
place for friends to come over and like
we have so many things here that you
could do you know training weights
pliability green juice like mirror work
let's go down the list of stuff you can
do here um and the goal is once we're
kind of beyond coveted everyone's kind
of vaccinated just like come through and
like hang out grab a workout grab a
green juice cry a little who knows you
know
but that's really the purpose of it
because i think that at least for me
everybody was forced into uh lockdown
but no one's forcing you to be social
right so i'm trying to promote more of
that
i've had a few friends around so far who
have been vaccinated and it's been so
cool to see them like feel better just
coming into an environment you know yeah
well we're in a major
major
point in history where all so many
things are being revealed and alchemized
and healed and so thank you for your
work danica it's been so awesome thanks
for having me what an incredibly awesome
interview
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button